wie kinder im fernsehen
instrumentalisiert wurden in dem sie
politikern fragen gestellt haben die
ganz offensichtlich keine kinder fragen
waren jetzt gibt es einen fall wo auch
politiker kinder instrumentalisieren auf
der letzte woche standen ja auch wieder
drei auch ihrem studio und da haben wir
auch schon über die die kinder
instrumentalisiert wenn im wahlkampf das
hat ja begonnen bei der prosieben
sendung wo kinder fragen gestellt haben
aber es war ein knopf zum ohren man halt
ganz klar gemerkt das sind doch gar
nicht die fragen der kinder ein beispiel
war wo armin laschet gefragt wurde ob
hans georg maßen ein nazi sei also seine
radtour sehr kinder zuerst auch kinder
ich nicht aber ich kann mir nicht
sonderlich gut vorstellen dass irgendwie
ein siebenjähriges kind hans-georg maßen
kennt jugendlichen geleast ja und jetzt
ist es aber anders eingetreten also
jetzt machen auch politiker mit kindern
wahlkampf insbesondere die grünen es gab
jetzt verschiedenen schweiz von
grünen-politiker einer hat zum beispiel
getwittert dass der elfjährige kann das
ist der andere von jeßnitz hat genau das
ist ja mit ich komme von einer
grundschule und bin am rollen die kinder
fragen zu rassismus warum frauen weniger
verdienen klimawandel und tierschutz
einer hat sich nach der stunde geoutet
weil ich so coole antworten zu
sexualität gegeben habe für diese jungen
menschen mache ich das alles der schule
muss man hier vorherigen also die
grundschulkinder interessieren sich
nicht dafür dass sie den ganzen tag
maske tragen müssen die grundstück
kinder interessieren sie auch nicht für
corona die grundstücke in der
interessieren sie auch nicht vielleicht
wenn mal wieder der sportunterricht
richtig toll möglich ist die kinder
interessieren sich nur für frauen quote
rassismus und den klimawandel und was
mich daran wirklich ankotzt ist dass die
kinder im wahlkampf missbraucht werden
für die eigene politische agenda und
kinder im wahlkampf zu benutzen ist
einer politik unwürdig und ich finde
auch das ist das politische ende wenn
man nicht mehr für sich selbst spricht
sondern immer kinder für sich sprechen
lassen muss um seine argumentation
nochmal gewicht zu verleihen ich finde
das grundlegend falsch und mich stört
dass auch allerdings ist das keine ganz
neue entwicklung und keine die nur die
grünen betrifft ich kann mich sehr gut
erinnern als ich kind war bin ich von
der cdu vor der schule angesprochen
worden ob ich nicht in die schüler union
eintreten will und zwar auch ganz
explizit mit dem ziel dort auch
wahlkampf dann zu machen nun sagen das
sind keine grundschüler sondern man kann
ab 13 jahren in die schüler union
eintreten aber immerhin das sind auch
kinder und schüler
das ist ein guter vergleich der aber
finde ich ein wenig hinkt weil der
wurdest du ja für ein politisches
engagement angesprochen von jemandem
direkt aber du wurdest nicht medial
benutzt ich finde bei diesen sachen dass
sie jetzt schon bei grundschülern
angefangen die kinder so benutzt werden
das andere beispiel was ich zuerst
erzählen wollte war er hat eine auf
berliner kandidatin hat dann gesagt der
elfjährige karl hätte sie gebeten nicht
mehr so zu trödeln was den klimawandel
betrifft und ich frag mich ob ein
politisches argument ich einfach stark
sein kann ohne dass ein kind zitiert
wird er ist eine totale
emotionalisierung bei gegen kinder sagt
niemand was und ich finde die grünen
missbrauchen da auch die kinder stimmt
für ihre eigene politische agenda das 13
jahre über 40 särge von der schule
angesprochen werden und abgeworben
werden für schüler union finde ich auch
nicht gut aber das geht für mich noch
einen schritt weiter und wolfram weimer
der publizist und verleger hat gestern
abend für die nacht bei unsere polit
talkshow gesagt das kennt man ja von
diktatoren wo die mit kindern posieren
wo den küsschen auf die wange gegeben
von kindern ist demokratin und
demokratische parteien sich dafür
eigentlich immer zu fein waren das ist
auf dem unwürdig ist für die parteien
und es sehe ich genauso man sollte
keinen wahlkampf mit kindern machen und
jetzt noch ganz zum schluss meiner meine
aufreger des tages lasse ich mich noch
zu einer these hinreißen ich glaube den
grünen das auch nicht jedes mal das ist
auch ein ganz großes problem für mich
ich glaube nicht dass in der grundschule
kinder nur über warum frauen weniger
verdienen rassismus und klimawandel
sprechen auch der elfjährige kam aber
wirklich als es ganz dringend themas
bitte bitte trödelt nicht mehr so sehr
das nervt mich am allermeisten es ist ja
auch noch alles anonymisiert ich kann
heute auch sagen ich war in einer
grundschule und dann haben die
grundschüler gesagt bitte keine
vermögenssteuer für deutschland bitte
nicht die wirtschaft muss nach kona
wieder wachsen bitte denkt an die
wirtschaft bitte denkt an die
arbeitsplätze meine eltern es ist doch
alles humbug der tat ich nämlich gerade
an eine wahlparty die wir zu hause mal
gemacht haben und da haben wir auch die
kinder abstimmen lassen und haben für
jede partei die farben der partei
angegeben die sie ankreuzen mussten und
das ergebnis war dass 99,9 prozent für
die linken gestimmt haben weil die
dieses schöne pinkl
kindern wichtig abstimmung das wäre doch
mal was nettes auch aber deswegen ich
bin ein bisschen sauer darüber sollte
man der beiden diesbezüglich vielleicht
gar nicht fragen es kommt aufs alte jahr
[Musik]